والامانه تقتضي ان نقول انهم ما زالوا
مؤثرين على قطاعات واسعه وما ذكره الاستاذ
بابكر فيصل صحيح بنسبه كبيره جدا المفاهيم
الرئيسيه مثلا
مفهوم الشمول هل يمكن الاسلام فعلا ان
يكون الشاملا بهذا المعنى
ومفهوم الحكم هذا الحكم الذي ورد في
القران يعني الحكم بالمعنى المعاصر هل
توجد دوله اسلاميه في الاسلام بهذا المعنى
المعاصر ما هي الشريعه التي تعنيها هل
الاحكام التي جاءت في الايات القرانيه
وطبقت في عهد النبي وبعده قليلا هل هي
الاحكام التي يمكن ان تسود الان هذه
المفاهيم فعلا تحتاج ان تفكك انا قرات قبل
مده كتاب جيد جدا كتبه احد اساتذه الفلسفه
والاستاذ فتح الرحمن التوم اسمه
كولونياليه الاسلام السياسي بدل مجهود
كبير في تفكيك هذه المفاهيم انا حتى الان
ما زلت اشتغل على تاريخ الحركه اشتغل في
الجزء الثالث من الكتاب وسميه تاملات
المقالات ولكن بعد ان افرق من هذه المساله
ساعمد فورا الى مناقشه اصول هذه الافكار
التي تبناها الاسلام السياسي وهي ليست
خاصه فقط بالاسلام السياسي ولكنها سائده
في كل المعاهد التقليديه التي تخرج كل عام
الاف المخرجين ويؤثرون هذا الاجتهاد
الواسع كانت الحركه في السودان منوطه به
مثلا عندما ذهبوا الى مفاوضات السلام مع
الجنوب لم يستطيعوا ان يصلوا الاتحاد
يستثني فقط العاصمه من تطبيق قوانين
الشريعه وانتهى الامر فصل ربع السودان
جنوب السودان اصبح دوله مستقله وكعب اخيل
والعقده كانت بقوانين الحدود رغم انها لا
تطبق